House Democrats released yesterday of
more than 3,500 russian-backed Facebook
ads is refocusing attention on social
media companies and their role in our
democracy Twitter revealed in January
that more than 50,000 accounts were
linked to Russia's attempts to interfere
in the 2016 presidential election Dick
Costolo served as Twitter CEO from 2010
to 2015 but before that he co-founded
and ran three startups including
Feedburner
the feed management provider was sold to
Google in 2007 for 100 million dollars
Dick Costolo joins us at the table
dick good morning morning first question
is Prince Harry going to keep the beard
or not 500 goodness I missed the bedding
part what do you say well so keeping it
or not there was new information
provided during the break we don't go
with the new information I'm saying he's
gonna shave okay ha I changed my mind
why did you okay why did you change what
spur but I was told he's gonna wear his
uniform and I think if you wear the
uniform you have to shave and the person
who gave you that information wasn't the
person on the other side of the mansion
changes it's all real time five minutes
ago okay but let's talk about this it's
widely believed that the Russian
certainly influenced the election in
2016 but do you believe that they change
the outcome and do you think there's
anything we need to be doing to get
ready for the midterms yeah so I think
it's very hard to say that they changed
the outcome there it's almost with with
what with 100% certainty I can tell you
that they meddled in trying to influence
people's opinions about the election and
I think that will be the case in 2018
midterms as well so now that we know
that what what should we be doing about
it well the challenges for these
companies Twitter and Facebook and
YouTube etc are traditionally the
hackers have been people in you know
people trying to steal account
information or get you to where spammers
who are trying to get you to click on a
link and buy something the challenge now
is that some of these hackers are state
actors like the Russians the Chinese to
some extent the Iranians and these state
actors aren't trying to get you to click
on something to take money from you
they're not trying to steal
account information they're just trying
to sway your opinion that's a much much
harder problem for these companies to
attack can I ask you something about the
pace of change you were at Twitter
between 2010 and 2015 when you watch how
fast things are changing now how fast
they change with Twitter can even
catching up to what's going on in the
new ways it's being used is that even
possible at a regulatory level or is
there some other way we have to look at
the pace of change the the pace of
change is extraordinary you saw it with
the Google assistant video you showed
earlier I mean we we tend to think that
artificial intelligence is a long ways
away and and now here it is and we're
asking if Google is going to announce
that it's a machine you're talking to or
not the notion that Met Congress who
during the interviews with Zuckerberg to
be perfectly frank seemed not up to
speed on what the platforms were like I
mean one of the folks even said to mark
my grandson William is on Instagram and
as if Mark like you know obviously you
know the notion that that people who are
not up to speed on these platforms are
going to be able to regulate them in
real-time is is probably not going to
probably not gonna happen let's be
honest they're free right Facebook is
free Twitter is free the only way these
companies make money is mobile
advertising correct handover all of our
data we hand over our age our gender our
professions some apps I've been on
missus they ask how much money you make
right over all this data right and
Twitter Facebook lots of other social
media platforms make money off
advertising price the cats out of the
bag right I mean where I don't see how
this is changing well it's interesting
you know when I was running Twitter the
the big challenge that we had was it was
considered a strategic advantage that
Facebook had all this information about
you personally that they could use to
help advertisers micro-target and and
Twitter didn't because you just had to
sign up with an account ID and a
password and that was it
that sort of flipped now that advantage
that Facebook had in some senses has
become people have become aware that
wait a minute I've given them an
extraordinary amount of information
maybe I shouldn't be doing that so there
are platforms where you don't have to
provide that information you don't on
Twitter that had previously be
considered a strategic disadvantage now
maybe it's an advantage but all things
in do you think we're better off with
Twitter and Facebook and those kind of
plans
and I know that and and we we've had
this discussion that the platform should
probably be a lot more aggressive about
dealing with abuse and I certainly have
said that before and believe that went
back to 2010 when I first started it as
CEO at Twitter that we should have been
a lot more aggressive about that but
it's also the case that these platforms
are a reflection of somewhat society's
dysfunction you've got a president who
calls people names on Twitter you know
he's modeling behavior that other people
in society are reflecting their cost so
great to have you here thanks for having
me